hi I'm Erik Bosse and stranger things
second season is here and once again
thank you to my parents and hip flicks
log in for a weekend it screams tears
laughs and nerdy jokes with a little
cane here of course stranger things is
so much more than a list of 80s
references but really a key part of this
show success is the way it evokes and
connects to these pop culture icons of
our collective pasts
that's right like it or not Spielberg
directed all of our childhood so let's
do this 80 or so details you might have
missed from stranger things season 2
spoilers ahead if you haven't seen the
full season yet what are you even doing
here your mouth breather and real quick
this video was sponsored by movement
watches and sunglasses check out the
description below for more info or stick
around to the end for details on a
special offer cool let's get started the
opening image of the second season is a
starry night sky which might look
familiar to you for one it's the same
exact shot that opens season 1 but also
both of these shots are referencing the
opening shot of ET the extra-terrestrial
ET is obviously one of the biggest
cultural influences on stranger things
and let's run through all of the many
pop culture influences in our section
under the influence and let start with
the et references the show leads back
into the ET connection in season 2 when
wil says his favorite candy Reese's
Pieces horse Reese's Pieces are the
candy Elliott uses to lure ET into his
bedroom late in the season
Dustin develops a similar relationship
with dart aka baby Dimmick organic a
demo dog feeding him his favorite
Halloween candy three musketeers and
later leading him with slices of Bologna
also notice how Dustin has an et statue
on his nightstand in his bedroom and on
Halloween night Dustin's mother dresses
in a similar black cat costume that
Eliot's mother wears an et and when
eleven wears a white ghost she'd hoping
hopper will take her out
trick-or-treating that's also a nod to
ETS Halloween costume disguise but the
fact that it's a jump-scare here
reminded me of Michael Myers disguise at
Halloween actually see max later scare
the boys with the regular Mike Myers
costume Elevens ghost sheet also
reminded me of that awesome scare and
paranormal activity 3 which I know isn't
an 80s movie not all these references
are going to be in the 80s but at least
that movie was set in the 80s another
influential eighties franchise was the
alien movies which was lightly touched
on in season 1 with the demo Gorgon
xenomorph II design but season 2 takes
it to a whole new level and it starts
with a casting of Paul
as dr. Sam Owens Reiser memorably played
Carter Burke and aliens the
untrustworthy weyland-yutani company man
who says I work for the company but
don't let that fool you I'm really a
good guy Owens definitely evokes that
untrustworthiness I need you to realize
I'm on your side course as the season
goes on
Owens actually ends up redeeming himself
staying behind to save hopper and the
others which is the exact opposite of
what Burke did to the crew in aliens
meanwhile Dustin wanted to keep a dead
Demma dog for science is exactly the
clearly idiotic thing Burke or Ashe
would do Joyce don't ever open that
fridge now the way season 1 heightens to
season 2 is clearly inspired by the way
James Cameron upped the ante with aliens
whereas the first season featured one
lone monster slowly stalking its victims
the second season multiplies the threat
dialing up the action even the demagogue
and biology is borrowing from the
xenomorph it incubates and implants
inside will the way the xenomorph
facehuggers do and it ends up crawling
away and growing into a larval stage
that molted as it outgrows its slimy
exoskeleton like the chest burster also
the demo dogs are quadruped 800 variants
on the original form
much like the xenomorph runner in alien
3 and the shot of mew-mew hissing a dart
and a trap is a nod to Jonesy the cat
hissing at the xenomorph an alien and my
favorite sequence of the season when
Owens send soldiers down into the
demagogue death trap this is all
recreation of the scene in aliens when
Burke watches as a soldiers heat signal
dots gets swarmed on radar and they get
taken out one by one they even included
this line all right
which is a direct quote from the
soldiers and aliens but stay frosty now
another big influence was the film The
Goonies Richard Donner and Steven
Spielberg's pirate adventure classic
which of course inspired the casting of
Sean Astin Mikey from that movie perhaps
the namesake of Mike wheeler here Astin
plays Bob newbie who's pretty much a
grown-up Mikey he's a nerd who's handy
with DIY gadgetry and not too rattled by
an adventure and he makes the most
obvious I wholly self-reference of the
season what's at the X pirate treasure
season 2 goes even further with this
Goonies parallel with Steve filling in
as Josh Brolin's character the reluctant
older brother dragged along but still
feels responsible for the kids now last
season I pointed out how the character
of Dustin was kind of a mix of mouth and
chunk and in the finale him calming down
dart with a three musketeer
it's very similar to chunk call me down
sloth with the baby route also notice
what the scientist says when the demo
dog comes out of the pit now maybe
that's just me but this reminds me of
the end of The Goonies when the adults
realize this kids story is actually real
Oh Mary Mother of God now in addition to
Goonies if you listen closely Bob's
childhood also seemed to come from
another 80 source material Stephen
King's it notice the story he tells will
in Episode three and there he is
mr. Waldo would you like would you like
a balloon how did another creepy clown
say that do you want to go to Intuit
Georgie dude okay like the kids from it
Bob grew up in Maine and he says that he
stood up to this clown and if you think
about the time line does work out
because in the book the kids grew up in
the 50s which is when Bob would have
been in Maine obviously I don't think
they're saying that bob was an actual
member of the losers Club it's just fun
to see how he's the type of kid who
would have been the works of Stephen
King are definitely an influence on
stranger things as was the case last
season eleven psionic abilities are
definitely inspired by books like Carey
and firestarter and once again this
season the kids walk the railroad tracks
like the kids and stand by me a movie
adapted from kings the body stand by me
also seems to influence another
character who's new Billy he's the
psychotic bully with a blonde mullet
just like Kiefer Sutherland's character
he also seems based partly on rob lowes
character from st. Elmo's fire who is
also named Billy I picked up some traces
of Breakfast Club John bender in there
but according to actor dr. Montgomery
the duffer's told them to watch Jack
Nicholson in the shining another Stephen
King adaptation Billy's sadistic
cackling as he fights with Steve
definitely seems inspired by Nicholson
this season also features a number of
aerial overhead shots of cars on rural
roads which could be nods to Kubrick's
opening shots of The Shining and the
look of the shadow monster as it emerges
from the clouds and Will's vision seems
to be pulled from the mist another King
adaptation the movie version of the mist
was directed by Frank Darabont who also
adapted Kings Rita Hayworth in the
Shawshank Redemption and episode six
pays homage to Darabont's iconic shot as
the camera crawls back from behind the
poster of said Rita Hayworth season two
is set in 1984 so now the kids world is
populated with tons of great
ghostbusters details obviously the boys
Halloween costumes and the repeat use of
Ray Parker jr. theme song but also in
Dustin's bedroom notice how he has this
Ghostbusters certificate of anti
paranormal proficiency you got one of
these if you were in the fan club Zubin
enhancing on this thing it authorizes
you to eradicate exterminate exercise
and/or entrap me and all supernatural
manifestations later on also you can
save the world on short notice also
notice that it's signed by race stance
which is probably why Dustin who went as
stance went ahead and busted this
supernatural manifestation of his
garbage actually this scene with him
nervously approaching guard seems like a
recreation of stances first encounter
with Slimer I think there's also some
Ghost Buster influence on the character
Marie Bowman the investigative reporter
hired by Barb's parents I think there's
a good chance that the duffer's named
Murray after bill murray Spangler after
all he is from Chicago like Murray and
Brett Gelman definitely seems to be
channeling Bill Murray's detached
wiseass oddball persona and his
portrayal of the character now as I said
the 80s weren't the only decade of pop
culture to influence stranger things and
these Jurassic Park parallels are a
great example like when Dustin traps
dart in the basement it evokes a scene
with the kids trapping the Raptor in the
kitchen freezer also when Steve Bates
the dimma dog in the scrap yard we get
this great reveal that there are in fact
several with one closing in on Steve
from this side just like the Raptors
hunting tactic in Jurassic Park he's no
Steve's like clever girl in Episode
eight the whole business with resetting
the breakers was also in Jurassic Park
and perhaps Bob newbies most heroic move
what's that in a straight with how
computers actually work if you want to
unlock the doors you have to completely
reboot the computer system and then
override the security codes with a
manual input fine how do I do that you
can't unless you know basic I hear that
that is the sound of nerds everywere
clapping they're sweaty hands Bob uses
actual computer coding to reset the
network which feels like a sly
commentary on Jurassic Park that's right
Spielberg expected us to buy that a
child could somehow operate a
non-existent UNIX system and swoop in
through a seedy suburb of files and
reboot the security system a task that
failed highly-paid chief engineer Sam
Jackson I mean I love the movie but come
on also this fat scientist is totally
Dennis Nedry I actually think
Spielberg's earlier monster movie had a
big influence as well jaws last season
we saw how chief Hopper was more or less
a version of chief Brody also will has a
jaws poster in his bedroom this season
in episode 6 Dustin and Steve this
season's ultimate power couple by the
way hey use a bucket of me to leave a
trail
the demo dog in their direction just
like Brody does with a shark also while
these kids wait in the scrapyard max
remarks that the fog makes the land
around them look like an ocean
indeed this scene that the kids bonding
in the calm before the storm definitely
had the feel of Brody Quint hopper in
the boat cabin and Jaws in fact I should
say this whole decision to name this
seasoned stranger things to like a movie
sequel is something that comes from Jaws
as well before that franchise true
movies sequels didn't really exist like
sure the Star Wars movies had sequels
but each of them had new titles and
there was the Godfather Part two but
really jaws 2 was the first to just put
a number after the title and more or
less try to repeat the success of the
first movie stranger things new title
card with the big red 2 behind the word
seems to be pulling from the design of
child's play - or screamed to another
80s movie reference I noticed was John
Carpenter's The Thing the monster
preferreds the cold and hates the heat
and fire even severed parts of it that
aren't physically attached to the main
body just like the alien monster in the
thing it also sets up the things
scenario of not being able to trust the
host body forcing you to tie the person
down I also think will is drawing on the
girl from The Exorcist with Joyce's
argument with the doctors reminded me a
lot of that film and wills inhuman
screams seemed very reminiscent of
Donald Sutherland screamin invasion of
the Body Snatchers of course we have to
mention the influence of gremlins on
this movie Dustin's relationship with
dart parallels Billy's with gizmo down
to feeding him junk food sneaked him
into school and the hard rule against
exposing him to light actually hoppers
three rules 411 could be a nod to the
three rules of gremlins now like last
season Dungeons & Dragons again served
as a metaphor analogy whatever for the
more complicated phenomena to happen the
boys use the term truesight to describe
wills ability to see in other dimensions
through sight is a real D&D ability that
does as Dustin describes allow you to
see into the ethereal plane they also
later identified the shadow monster as
the mind flayer describing its psionic
powers and desire to enslave all other
races in D&D the mind flayer is also
called an ilithyia it's categorized as a
lawful evil and it has a tentacled face
which may have inspired the tentacle
design of this creature but whereas last
season the opening game of D&D
foreshadowed the plot events of the
season that followed this season it's an
arcade game the opening scene features
the boys playing Dragon's Lair which is
a real game that's super expensive
especially since it was really hard to
get to the final stage that's why the
boys had to gather a ton of quarters in
the opening scenes here it's
interesting how dustin and lucas butt
heads over the high score in rescuing
the two sexy for kids game princess
daphne which actually foreshadows these
two boys fighting for Max's love later
on also the other game of Dig Dug for
shadows the digging and underground
tunnels that hopper and the others do
later in the season
there's also another 80s video game
reference with the kid rest of his
pac-man on Halloween later once again
this season hopper seems to invoke
Indiana Jones especially at the end of
episode 4 with his silhouette and his
had definitely taking a very indie shape
in the next episode he even loses his
hat at one point and grabs it and in the
final episode Nancy burns will with a
fireplace poker to weaken him and save
Joyce similar to how short round burns
Indy with a torch to break his trance
and save Willy in Temple of Doom and
then again not an eighties reference but
wills telepathic connection with the
shadow monster seems at least a bit
influenced by Harry Potter's connection
with Voldemort in order of the Phoenix
he and Mike realized that will and the
monster can spy on each other that also
leaves them both exposed just like Harry
and Voldemort using the legitimacy spell
on each other and making them both
vulnerable and I'm a bit of a stretch
but will is the wizard of the group and
obviously there are a ton of one-off
eighties pop-culture references so I'll
quickly run through the others that I
noticed maxes arcade name is Mad Max
reference to Mel Gibson Mad Max series
the nerd of the arcade calls a road
warrior in a future episode a reference
to the sequel on the TV 11 sees a
trailer for terminator which is playing
at the Hawkins Hawk right after it
screening I'm sure of all the right
moves starring Nancy the [ __ ] wheeler 11
also watches Susan Lucci early on in her
run for the soap opera All My Children
the videos Jonathan ransom you look
closely are mister mom but also wargames
and Twilight Zone the movie Dustin named
his turtle urinal a reference to the dr.
Seuss character yertle the turtle never
support notice the basketball scene set
to push it to the limit this is a
reference to that song being used in the
cheesy montage of Scarface but it also
feels like a reference to the Top Gun
volleyball scene yeah there is
definitely a maverick Iceman vibe
between Steve and Billy later on the
character of eight Holly is named after
the Hindu goddess Kali the destroyer of
evil forces in the background of our
hideout there's graffiti reading o
bedlam King mob and battle if those are
all character names from Grant
Morrison's the Invisibles it's about
resistance movement fighting against
people who harm those with psychic
powers does that mean we're in store for
a spin-off with Kali and her crew hope
not there's kind of a Star Wars vibe to
Elevens training with Kali she moves a
train car similar to Luke trying to lift
the x-wing Carly makes a living loose
Nate dr. brenner just like Luke seen
Vader in the cave and sure she just kind
of forced choke this guy kind of like
Vader with Admiral mati actually on the
TV in the scene this guys watching the
sitcom Punky Brewster specifically an
episode where punky is dreaming about
scientists sticking her with needles
definitely a connection to xi there and
steve daring to face the demo dog in a
scrap yard as the oldest and bravest kid
seems inspired by Benny the jet the
Sandlot risking his life to face a
monster dog in a scrap yard be bloodbath
in the Hawkins lab is dee-lightful it
totally parallels the one in cabin in
the woods especially this shot with a
scientist watching the horror over video
monitors actually cabin in the woods is
an amazing movie that references many of
these same eighties references that
stranger things does and Dustin's
appearance in the final scene is modeled
on ducky and pretty and Bank down to him
getting to dance with the prettiest girl
there as always a stranger things the
attention to detail is amazing with a
ton of 80s era branding and every frame
down to Steve quoting KFC's finger
looking good ad campaign the classic
three musketeers wrap in old cans of dr.
pepper and tab and Steve easing Farrah
Fawcett's Faberge brand hairspray and
alongside these pop culture influences
were some real-world current event
influence as well you probably noticed
all the reagan-bush signs on front yards
a reference to the 1984 election which
would have been the following week I
also like how Dustin's mom has a Mondale
Ferraro sign and her yard for the
Democratic candidates who got crushed in
that election
mrs. wheeler also mentions over the
phone that she likes Margaret Thatcher
sounded like she was debating Geraldine
Ferraro as a female political role model
and mrs. wheeler was more of a fan of
Thatcher's Reagan style conservatism as
British prime minister there's also a
newspaper headline reading baby phase
baboon hard which was a real live
medical case that seemed like a huge
breakthrough unfortunately the patient
died three months later
and speaking of tragedies Lucas has a
model of the Challenger Space Shuttle on
his desk
also notice the line for mr. wheeler in
Episode two understood we're all
Patriots it's not surprising that mr.
wheeler would say this but it also helps
explain how the events of season 1 were
kept secret in 80's Cold War America
loyalty to country especially in a
household like the wheelers was a huge
deal and if the Hawkins lab scandal
could be framed as a matter of national
security it makes sense that these
families could keep quiet about it now
of course there were a ton of eighties
references in the Halloween party and
I'll come back to those later but for
now I want to point out the interesting
connections this season made across
episodes in our segment
callbacks in the first episode hop
secretary wordlessly takes a cigarette
from him just like she does in the first
episode of last season and then notice
the useless cliche mr. wheeler throws it
a sign so if your friend jumps off a
cliff you're gonna jump too
useless especially considering the fact
that Mike of all kids knows what it
means to literally jump off a cliff for
his friend the Millennium Falcon toy
that might consider is giving away is a
callback to season 1 this is the same
toy that 11 levitated in a basement and
Mike wasn't home when she did that
making it interesting that he would feel
that significance or maybe he just
rightfully doesn't want to give away the
best toy ever then notice what Jonathan
says to will who'd you rather be friends
with Bowie or Kenny Rogers Oh exactly
it's no contest I love this line and
it's a subtle callback to episode 4 of
last season when wills alleged body was
found in the quarry the music that
played over it was a cover of David
Bowie's heroes
the next episode makes another callback
to Bob loving kenny rogers when he
enjoys dance - Kenny Rogers and Dolly
Parton's duet islands of the stream also
when Hopper teaches new words to 11
notice how he spells compromised Co M
promise it's interesting that he uses
the word promise because she already
knows the word promise remember that the
word Mike taught her in season 1 I won't
tell her about you I promise promise
also like how later this season 11
corrects the truck driver I won five
Larrabee right this is a callback to
this scene with hopper when he corrects
how she says time five one five five
fifteen when dr. Owens shows Nancy and
Jonathan through the lab he assumes that
they're together which is kind of a
callback to when he called Joyce and
Hopper mom and pop in Episode one
assuming they were together it's kind of
interesting now in both cases that sort
of ends up being true by the end of the
season in episode 7 notice what 11 calls
the [ __ ] Chicago guy not breathing
this is another useful word 11 learned
in season 1 remember she directed it at
the manager of the supermarket math
breather and I love Steve trying to
weigh in on Dustin's explanation of the
mind flayer it believes it's the master
race like the Germans this is a callback
to episode 1 when Steve wrote about his
grandfather's war stories in his college
essay you think about it his grandfather
probably still called the people he
fought the Germans now still laughed
when Dustin scoffed at hopper suggesting
that they throw fireballs in the monster
this of course is a callback to the
opening D&D game in episode 1 a season 1
when Lucas told will to use fireball and
Dustin disagreed oh you [ __ ]
fireball didn't cast protection and
Dustin getting dance with Nancy at the
end is a callback to that same first
episode when he was crushing on her but
she wouldn't give me the time of day I
just really loved how the end game of
the final two episodes of this season
really mirrored a lot of story elements
from before they worked together to
create a sensory deprivation room for
will calling back the tub that they
built for 11:00 last season and this
room happens to be the buyers backyard
shed the exact same location will
initially disappeared
hopper awesomely tosses Nancy the rifle
since she's the best shot of course I
call back to her sharp shooting skills
in season 1 and yeah once again pretty
boy Steve gets rekt that makes him over
2 against Jonathan and now
we're now Steve Harrington's likability
is directly proportional to the number
of bruises on his face
actually this shows self aware treatment
of Steve is one of the best examples of
stranger things medic humor so let's go
over all the other examples in our
segment so meta episode 6 gives us two
meta nods at everyone's mixed feelings
for Steve one from Dustin no one is
around why do you think I'm Steve
Harrington and earlier Murry teases
Nancy and Jonathan's will they won't
they chemistry and Steve's likability
comes up there too Steve we like Steve
yes I think my favorite line of the
season was Dustin calling out mr.
wheelers uselessness this is a grown man
and he's just so checked out of the
story that he only responds to Dustin's
profanity here but probably the most
overt meta commentary came from max
later this episode after Lucas
summarized the events of season 1 to her
it's crazy but I really liked it liked
it yeah well I mean I had a few issues
issues I just felt was a little
derivative in parts is Max's echoing the
talking points of the critics of season
one who'd liked this show but complain
that it was a little too dependent on
pop culture references and derivative of
80 Spielberg's not true leave stranger
things alone ok moving on now to some of
the really subtle choices made by the
show this season starting with some of
the audio elements I really liked in our
segment to hear that now the music of
stranger things is fantastic both this
song selection and the score composed by
Kyle Dixon and Michael Stein I don't
want time to go into how all of these
songs are perfectly appropriate so I'll
just single out the final song of the
season I'll be watching you by the
police notice how right as we hear
stings saying Oh can't you see you
belong to me the world rotates the
upside down version of the gym with the
shadow monster looming over watching and
possessing them reminding us that yes
this song is creepy we should never slow
dance to it really I love these sound
mixing this season specifically the way
it brought us into wills head there were
key sound effects that were amplified
designed to trigger a specific emotion
in Episode one as will goes in for a
checkup notice how each of the straps
and the plunging of the syringe play
really loudly
this is meant to convey wills anxiety
but also these shadow monsters early
stages of control as if it's worried
about being detected in episode 2 when
hopper visits with Joyce we get this
close-up of him lighting a cigarette
listen closely they have the whole flick
and the flame roar like a torch this
reflects will in the shadow monsters
resistance to fire in heat and later in
Episode four after the shadow monster
has fully possessed will enjoy straws
maja bat a similar tortilla roar plays
the moment Joyce turns on the water all
the sound mixing is equated heat with
something super threatening okay moving
on let's lean in and look closely at
some of these subtle visual choices made
in this season in our segment zoom
animates okay early in Episode one we
get this close up of these souls of
hoppers boots on his desk and notice how
they're covered in dirt I think this
foreshadow is the reveal that comes at
the end of this episode that Hopper has
been secretly living with eleven in a
cabin deep in the woods next in Episode
two eleven receives a Morse code
transmission from hopper and notice what
channel number they use eleven episode
seven introduces us to Kali aka eight
and if you look closely the number eight
appears a few key times throughout this
episode right before the opening credits
and later when eleven enters the
warehouse there's an Eightball on the
wall on the right now Billy's flirting
with mrs. wheeler in Episode nine is one
of these stranger moments of stranger
things and I like how they set it up
with this Joanna Lindsey romance novel
check out the cover the guy is a similar
hairstyle and open chest that Billy had
it's kind of justifying why mrs. wheeler
would be all over this kid now this
final shot of the season as the camera
tilts and rotates to the upside down is
actually foreshadowed at several key
points earlier this season the show used
this same iconic camera movement in the
final shot of Episode four the final
shot of Episode five and with Bob's
death an episode eight and there's a
really heartbreaking admissible detail
that centers around the blue bracelet
that hopper wears so as we saw in season
one hopper used to have a daughter named
Sarah who passed away from cancer she
wore blue hair braids which hopper
turned into a bracelet when Sarah lost
her hair from chemotherapy
he continued to wear that bracelet long
after she died and has continued to wear
it throughout season two but then in the
final scene of this season look where
that braid ends up on Elevens wrists now
that hopper has legally adopted her he
has finally begun to
move on from Sarah's death and begin a
new family
no you stop crying okay let's close out
by zooming and enhancing Tina's
Halloween party in Episode two probably
the most densely packed with details of
the season all shot in one take as the
camera follows the action inside okay
first we get Billy doing a keg stand
there's a like a virgin Madonna and Alex
Owens from Flashdance rocky from his
training montage and Johnny from The
Karate Kid and on the way inside there's
this caveman randomly hitting himself in
the head then there's this badass with a
googly eye glasses shaking his head as
Billy passes him he weirdly tugs on his
toilet paper and wraps in his hands
Nancy and Steve are dressed as Tom
Cruise and Rebecca De Mornay from risky
business though in somewhat less
memorable looks from the film then Nance
leads us into the kitchen with more
great details someone wrote ragin sucks
with anarchist a and sharp B on the
fridge this pure fuel guy is Bluto from
Animal House and look where he uses a
sponge to wipe his armpits and some hero
put the phone in the blender because why
not
later when Jonathan arrives we see blue
taupe you outside and then a girl
dressed as Siouxsie Sioux from the
British punk band Siouxsie and the
Banshees
and shortly after that there's a Lynda
Carter Wonder Woman a workout Jane Fonda
and a Billie Jean Michael Jackson now
there was a really fun horror movie
homage I noticed early in the season but
I covered it in my review of stranger
things 2 on Stardust you can download
the Stardust app by clicking our link in
the description below or follow us at
new rockstars and post your reactions
and tag us in them so that we can
feature you in our weekly panel show
they need to know which pop-culture
influence do you think translated the
best into stranger things to aliens
Jurassic Park Ghostbusters gremlins
comment down below and tweet me your
thoughts about this or about stranger
things as a whole a ta vas you can also
follow new rockstars on Twitter at new
rockstars for updates on our videos now
a quick thanks to movement for
sponsoring this video
movement offers super stylish watches
and sunglasses that I wear all the time
they have this sleek minimalist design
that I'm a big fan of because as many of
you pointed out in past videos my
fashion has historically kind of stuck
maybe this badass wolf excluding I think
you'd be surprised how well a classy
movement watch wear sunglasses cleans
you up but watch this start at 95 bucks
as sunglasses 70 bucks and even get them
polarized check it out all I need now is
some Farrah Fawcett fabergé spray and I
am ready
to get my ass kicked anyway I love this
stuff check it out get $15 off today
plus free shipping and free returns just
go to MBM t.com slash rock stars and
piece of code new rock stars when
checking out or you can click on the
link in the description anyway guys join
the movement and I am not cool enough to
pull it off like and share this video
and subscribe to new rock stars for all
of our breakdowns and analysis of things
that you love like the movie it we just
have a video to come out on that and if
you want to help us make more videos
like this you can contribute to us on
patreon big thanks to all of our current
donors especially Kenny Smith alright
thanks for watching bye